En los últimos años la presencia de
China en el continente africano ha
crecido vertiginosamente y ya en 2009
superó a los Estados Unidos como primer
socio comercial de la zona de del año
2000 el comercio bilateral entre china y
África sea multiplicado por 22 hasta superaron los 220
mil millones de dólares para hacernos
una idea de la enorme apuesta de China
cabe destacar que hoy su inversión
directa es mayor en África que en los
mismísimos Estados Unidos. Es en este
contexto en el que muchas personas que
se olvidan que el comercio nunca ha sido
la fuente de pobreza están mostrando
sistemáticamente su preocupación
acerca de los efectos que esta invasión
puede tener en las economías de los
países africanos.
"Ahora con los chinos
tomamos todos los préstamos posibles y
para todos los proyectos son ellos los
que gestionan, no hay ningún control"
Hay numerosos mitos acerca de quién
mueve a China, el gigante asiático,
hoy vamos a tratar de desmontar los tres
principales los tres más recurrentes.
Las estadísticas no avalan en modo
alguno este mito
y es que gracias en buena medida al
incremento de la inversión extranjera
directa, entre las que se encuentran
claro está la china, el crecimiento
económico de África se ha disparado
los últimos 15 años.
Así según datos del Banco Mundial entre
el año 2002 y año 2011 de la pobreza
se redujo en un 20 por ciento
Y esta es una dinámica que se está
acelerando en buena medida gracias a la
llegada de productos low cost de China
que están incrementando el poder
adquisitivo de los consumidores
africanos y les está permitiendo
dedicarse a aquellas actividades donde son
realmente competitivos
"Me gusta la tienda china por los colores,
los materiales y sobre todo los acabados
y encima es asequible"
En cualquier caso como
decíamos China es ya el primer socio
comercial de la región y
la creciente demanda de sus más de mil
millones de habitantes están aumentando
las exportaciones y las ganancias de las
empresas africanas
Además ya muchas empresas chinas
plantean iniciar procesos de
internacionalización y deslocalización
que estableciéndose en África, una
tierra amiga gracias a las relaciones que
se han establecido.
Tampoco podemos olvidar los importantes
proyectos de infraestructura que China
está desarrollando por todo África, proyectos
entre los que podemos encontrar puertos
como el de Lamú en Kenia,
aeropuertos como el de Maputo en Mozambique
o líneas de ferrocarril como la que
está llamada a conectar que Kenia, Uganda
y Ruanda.
Todos ellos proyectos estratégicos
esenciales para el desarrollo económico
y que requieren cientos y cientos de
millones de dólares para su ejecución
Además claro está de tecnología y
requerimientos técnicos
Hoy las calles y el skyline de Maputo están a
pleno rendimiento,
una de las últimas joyas de la capital de
Mozambique es el nuevo y más grande
hotel cinco estrellas
detrás de él se encuentra la empresa
china de construcción Anhui que desde
1996 a desarrollado las obras más
importantes del gobierno como el
aeropuerto internacional y el estadio
nacional
En esta línea en el marco del Foro de
Cooperación África-China el pasado mes
de diciembre el presidente chino Xi
Jinping comprometió ni más ni menos
que 60 mil millones de dólares para
estimular la industria y la agricultura
en el continente negro así como para
desarrollar infraestructuras de todo
tipo: puertos, aeropuertos, carreteras
núcleos logísticos, redes eléctricas y
un largo etcétera
Es cierto que hay más millón de chinos trabajando en
África y que tanto China como sus
empresas suelen trasladar a sus propios
trabajadores especialmente si hablamos
de técnicos para realizar los proyectos
en este continente.
Pero los datos
también nos muestran otra realidad.
Por ejemplo en el caso de Kenia, uno
de los mayores receptores de capital
chino y para el cual tenemos datos fidedignos. Bueno pues las estadísticas
para este país nos muestran que las
empresas chinas contratan a más
trabajadores keniatas que a trabajadores chinos.
"800 trabajadores locales están
trabajando aquí son parte de los más
de 25.000 keniatas empleados para el
proyecto, como parte del acuerdo entre
Kenia y China
la compañía está impartiendo formación
especializada a los locales"
Así el 74% de los puestos de trabajo a
jornada completa y el 93% de los puestos
de trabajo a tiempo parcial caen en
manos de trabajadores africanos
"Me ha gustado este
tipo de trabajo desde pequeño, quiero
aprender y poder abrir mi propia
compañía algún día"
Y de hecho el
pasado año la mayoría de las empresas
chinas establecidas en este país
tenían planes para sustituir a mano de
obra china por mano de obra Keniata.
¿Y esto por qué? Pues muy sencillo
simplemente porque le resultaba más
barato.
Durante 1998 y el 2012 más de 2.000
empresas se establecieron e invirtieron
en 49 países de África. Hoy hay más de
4.000 proyectos de inversión
ejecutándose en todo el continente y la
mayor parte de ellos corresponden a
empresas privadas y no a empresas estatales
dependientes de Pekin. Además lejos de lo que
podríamos esperar los proyectos de
inversión no se centran en las materias
primas sino que son los sectores de
servicios y manufacturas los que
aglutinan el mayor número de proyectos.
Simple y llanamente negocios e influencia. Y vale, probablemente también control
político pero en definitiva nada
diferente de lo que han buscado las
potencias occidentales durante
muchísimos años.
"Lo que ha hecho China diferente es muy
simple:
vinieron y nos dijeron 'necesitamos
vuestras materias primas,
necesitamos vuestro petróleo, vuestro
cobre y para asegurar el suministro por
cinco o diez años -porque los chinos
tienden a pensar en plazos más largos-
estaremos encantados de daros préstamos
los cuales vais a devolvernos no con
dinero sino con vuestras materias primas.
Podéis construir carreteras, trenes; podéis
construir así vuestras infraestructuras"
Solo que además parece
que en este caso la variable fundamental,
la más importante, son los negocios y es
que tenemos que pensar que África va a
ser el continente que más va a crecer
del siglo XXI y ya entre el año 2001 el año
seis de las diez economías que más
crecieron de todo el mundo se
localizaban en este continente y no
estamos hablando de excepciones, el
crecimiento medio de la mayoría de las
naciones africanas osciló entre el 5 y
el 6% en la última década.
Además áfrica es un continente inmenso
equiparable a la suma de Europa, Estados
Unidos, China, la India y Argentina que
concentra el 60% de las
tierras cultivables y al menos el 40% de las reservas de oro, el 30%
de los depósitos minerales y el
10% del gas y el petróleo
convencional conocidos. Todo ello nos
muestra el enorme potencial que tiene
este continente.
"La gente dice que China es el futuro, pero si preguntas a los chinos todos te dirán que es África quien lo es"
Es cierto que existen dudas
razonables sobre la calidad y la
conveniencia de muchas de las
infraestructuras que China promueve,
sobre el cuidado del medio ambiente, el
respeto a los derechos laborales y los
efectos de apuntalar a regímenes
dictatoriales y corruptos. Pero nadie
dijo que el camino hacia la prosperidad
fuese ni fácil ni rápido. ¿Qué pensáis
vosotros? ¿Conseguirán las inversiones
y el comercio con China desarrollar este
continente? ¿Caerá África en manos del
gigante asiático?
Espero que te ha gustado este vídeo, si
ha sido así suscríbete al canal.
¡Un saludo y hasta la próxima!